c'est la roche bonsoir en soi évidemment
tout le monde se demande ce qui a bien
pu pousser ce copilote a entraîné dans
la mort avec lui 149 personnes
alors vous êtes un ancien pilote est ce
qu'on évalue la santé mentale
psychologique des pilotes des pilotes
comme on évalue très bien apparemment
leur santé physique mais ça dépend du
parcours d'entrée dans l'industrie dans
certaines académies très structuré où
l'armée le les tests d'entrée sont très
sérieux et le parcours sur trois ou
quatre années il va faire en sorte qu'on
vit avec le candidat et on est capable
de déceler certains comportements dans
certains autres courts plus rapides on
n'a pas cette option là une fois al
embauche on va passer un examen médical
avec un médecin à chaque année qui est
pas psychiatre et psychologue mais qui a
quand même à coeur la sécurité aérienne
dans les grandes compagnies les médecins
sont résidents alors ils voient
régulièrement toujours les mêmes pilotes
on devient assez connu un problème ça
c'est beaucoup plus facile on y
connaissent nos enfants ils connaissent
la situation matrimoniale lors s'il y
avait des changements d'humeur du
changement vers le vert la dépression
par exemple c'est facile à voir et les
grands transporteurs ont des programmes
des deux noms punitif
alors quand des gens sont diagnostiqués
et avec un besoin des aides sont très
bien traités ça c'est peut-être la
prévention la plus efficace qu'on a
établi dans notre industrie plus
efficace qu'un test ou une évaluation
psychologique ou psychiatrique chaque
année comme on le ferait avec lui cette
évaluation physique
le problème avec un test psychiatriques
ou psychologiques 6 une photo comprend
la journée même si tu restes d'un pauvre
prédicteurs c'est pas facile de prédire
l'humeur dans cinq six mois dans un an
dans cinq ans avec ça alors des épisodes
de grande noirceur comme ça même les
psychiatres en perdent leur latin quand
vient le temps d'évaluer la dangerosité
d'un individu dans le temps mais vous
dans ce cas si vous dites au fond c'est
pas un test psychiatriques ou
psychologiques qui aurait pu changer les
choses mais c'est pas tout à fait on
sait pas vraiment mais la prédiction
d'un et au noir comme ça dans le temps
c'est pas tout à fait facile alors
qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire quelle
serait la solution au fond pour essayer
de prévenir ce genre de situation les
manufacturiers et la nasa travaille sur
une une partie technologique qui va au
moment où le pilote va se retrouver seul
dans cockpit réduire l'autorité de ce
pilote leur restreindre l'étendue des
changements majeurs dans la route de vol
qui va pouvoir faire on va lui lit on va
revendre tolérance il va pouvoir
manoeuvrer dans l'atmosphère faire un
déroutement pour la météo et tout mais
avoir des changements catastrophique
dramatique de plan de vol
varone censure électronique jusqu'au
moment où le second pilote reviennent
parce qu'on voit ça naturellement et une
harmonie dans le cockpit
il ya une unanimité convient d'en faire
des changements si on retire un pilote
on n'a plus cette unanimité la va
falloir un ce train de l'autorité
jusqu'à temps que l'autre viennent et si
le pilote ne revient pas mais à ce
moment là la nasa travaille sur un
projet d'avoir un pilote en stand by au
sol qui va participer à la décision par
télémétrie
on verra si tout ça sera
misant mise en oeuvre merci beaucoup
mais ça l'arrangé bien c'est à vous